this is a great question let's talk about it
an abortion is a termination of a pregnancy
and this may need to be done for a wide range of reasons
an abortion may be necessary to complete an otherwise incomplete miscarriage
or an individual may have pre existing conditions
or just generally have conditions that are being exacerbated by their pregnancy
and they need to terminate their pregnancy
a person may need to terminate their pregnancy
so that they can receive things like cancer treatment
the pregnant individual may be a child whose body is literally too small
but they face significant added health risks
if they are forced to continue the pregnancy
those are just a few examples
but it's really important to note that all abortions are medically necessary
because we know that it is incredibly dangerous
to force people to continue their pregnancies
against their will it is not just some minor inconvenience to a person
pregnancy is incredibly dangerous and could cost them their life
their health their reproductive organs
and in no other area of this country
do we force people to sacrifice themselves or their organs
for any other person's life
so we don't force people or even dead people to give their organs
despite all the people dying waiting on the organ donor list
and we don't force people to give blood
so yeah
there you have it um
I hope this was helpful and let me know if you have any other questions